oh how about the [ __ ] David Guetta
thing let me just tell you something
about David Guetta I don't know David
Guetta at all I bet David Guetta
for some reason is the nicest
[ __ ] in the world dude when I
look at David Guetta I just think now
that guy that guy's probably the nicest
[ __ ] in the world I imagined for
some reason David Guetta is just a guy
that's like to his friend that's like
yeah but turn about his new cars as they
you have here's the money for the car I
don't care I don't know what kind of
accent he has I think he's French I
can't do that one but it's so funny that
when a when a when a white guy says a
hint of a racist thing he can be
cancelled but when he's foreign
everyone's like ads no he's talking
about he's French
David Guetta goes like this
first of all it's weird that he's DJing
because he's DJing to nobody because of
kovat you know he's on the [ __ ] top
of a building
dude you're DJing for nobody just do it
in a basement somewhere why are you
going to the top of building alright why
are you doing that nicest guy ever
so anyway oh boy inspector [ __ ] incluso
the world is going through difficult
times so [ __ ] general love it nicest
guy of all time wearing a shirt that
John popper would wear in swingers and
America to the world is going through
difficult times and America to actually
like America as its own planet love it
already and America too actually dude
when you're trying to be [ __ ]
poignant leave the word actually out of
it okay so last night
I knew we were gonna do this and I made
a special record
so this record is in honor of George
Floyd on this record is in honor of
George Floyd
sounds like he almost messed the name up
we're gonna give it to him okay
foreign s foreign we'll give it to him
no he's French
when already things are so difficult
this is where it really kicks off into
[ __ ] high gear dude it's like okay
okay okay he's foreign he's struggling
with the English language all good kind
of odd the whole thing's kind of odd but
then he [ __ ] immediately turns it to
[ __ ] Mactan after this okay
shout out to his family the guy just
died you know oh [ __ ] dude what happened
oh oh your [ __ ] dad died bro shout
out to your family imagine that a
funeral and the most important thing we
have to do is receive the shout outs
from DJs so far David Guetta has shouted
out and other DJs should follow but
remember collect those shout outs
receive them and then he can they drop
some he's the beat gets really put it
starts swelling Mach 10 oh you think oh
you want to go to Mach 11 you want to go
to Mach 11 shout-out to the dead guys
family you want to go to Mach 11 do
[Music]
he remixed Martin Luther King jr. and
then did this I mean dude imagine you're
in Vegas and this hog was on and you
were like dancing with the chicken lady
I'm gonna [ __ ] this chick tonight dude
I'm just a [ __ ] huge boner up against
her crotch just like damn pump you want
another jacket coke what you want
another jacket coke shout-out to his
family don't do Bank Bank don't do bank
the bank you know David get is a really
[ __ ] nice guy you'll buy your car if
you want but honestly this is one of
those things where you got to give the
[ __ ] just you got it he's
raising money I think for this and it's
just it is funny and here at the
congratulations podcast aka called we'll
all get the log cabin soon sharing ideas
but this no knock on David Geffen the
[ __ ] his name David Guetta but yeah it
does definitely seem like something